on the 11th of November 1918 what had
been the biggest conflict so far in
human history finally came to an end
Germany capitulated and signed the
Treaty of Versailles the war changed the
world especially in Eastern Europe where
three empires crumbled new States
emerged new ideologies too and in many
places there was more bloody conflict
this is the story of the First World War
told from the Eastern European
perspective four great powers failed to
survive the war they even disappeared
from the map austro-hungary and the
Russian German and ottoman empires all
fell apart new states emerged in Eastern
Europe nearly all began feuding with
their neighbors over ideology territory
maritime access and natural resources
one ideology came to the fore communism
the first world war was a disaster for
Russia that Tsar had plenty of troops
but lacked equipment from the start the
Russians were not fully committed to the
war morale collapsed fully in 1917 that
Tsar was overthrown the communist party
took power and sealed a peace treaty
with Germany but it didn't bring peace
Russia plunged into a civil war lasting
years
populations in the South wanted to set
up their own nation-states Bosnian Serbs
Croats and Slovenes but then a secret
agreement between Italy and the
victorious powers came to light in
return for their assistance in the war
the Italians were promised strategic
assets in Croatia Italy claimed Croatian
ports and harbours right where Croatia
planned to set up its own state in 1919
the southern Europeans had to change
course to fend off the Italians they
established a joint umbrella state the
kingdom of Yugoslavia but the
populations of this new entity did not
get on well together unrest seethed for
decades breaking out into a bloody civil
war 75 years later now the people of
southern Europe have their own national
identities the founding of Ukraine was
equally convoluted as soon as the war
ended Ukraine fell into dispute with
Poland one argument was over the city of
l''ve if it was Eastern Europe in a
microcosm poles lived in the center of
live if Ukrainians in the area around
the city so where was the border to be
drawn l'viv became polish today it's
once again Ukrainian just as with
Ukraine and Poland border disputes in
Eastern Europe often hinged on
nationality villages a few kilometers
apart often spoke different languages
people went to separate schools and sold
themselves as part of another country
Eastern Europe is still preoccupied by
where borders should be drawn feelings
of national identity rarely accord with
the lines on a map it was a similar
story in Bulgaria which found itself on
the losing side in the first world war
the country had to give away territory
make payments to the victors and take in
large numbers of refugees from the
border areas so - in Hungary which lost
well over half of its sovereign
territory Europe became aware of its
ethnic minorities once the war ended the
need to protect them was evident and
remains so today
six months after the end of the war
Romania started another attacking
Hungary and regaining parts of the
country which still supports a Hungarian
minority as it happened Romania reverted
communism in Hungary to communist leader
béla kun fled following the fall of
Budapest when the Romanians withdrew
Hungarian army seized power after the
first world war Poland regained its
national territory following more than
200 years under foreign occupation three
and a half million Ukrainians also lived
there a million Russians and a million
Germans the post-war order was committed
to protecting these minorities it was a
difficult and unpopular undertaking for
the Polish government and the cause of
much strife poles had no desire to build
schools and universities for Ukrainians
and Germans so 100 years on is the
impact of the First World War still
being felt in today's Eastern Europe for
certainly border disputes continue to
torment the region between Serbia and
Kosovo for example and the emergence of
new states has meant new minorities and
interned the scourge of discrimination
the truce of 1918 might have ended what
was sometimes called the Great War but
it didn't bring lasting peace to the
people of Central and Eastern Europe